can you kill me I need to respond
headshot
Aaron Tipton here with a few thoughts on
the h1z1 Alpha face it people there's
been some language drift between
developers and players over the past
decade and nobody knows who shot first
h1z1 is listed on Steam as early access
what does that even mean everyone used
to know what a demo was what a beta was
and players never saw alphas because
developers didn't want to show people
their dirty laundry let me help you out
the word demo has pretty much been
banished to post game launch when
developers aren't selling enough copies
and decide they need to entice players
in games like titanfall in battlefield
won't say the actual word demo but they
now have trial periods a beta is now
code for a soft launch of a nearly
completed game basically it's there to
develop a player base before developers
claim an actual launch and then try and
rheic site that player base that they
already have think Ghost Recon online
planetside 2 or the destiny beta in
general you can expect a pretty polished
experience then there's the Alpha what a
beta used to be a broken mess of an idea
that developers are crafting into a
functional experience h1z1 is an alpha
like in actual alpha a game in the phase
of production where developers typically
cram a roomful of testers and then pay
the massive overtime to find bugs
the game developer will then prioritize
those bugs into what players are most
likely to encounter or not and then fix
the most glaring / cost-efficient errors
before shipping the title of the
mass-market h1z1 is therefore an
incomplete not bug tested title as
demonstrated by the initial server
instability floating arrows here's
killing you from 30 feet away cabinets
initially not spawning loot in the game
we're searching for loot is pretty much
half of the main thing to be fair patch
this week has already addressed some of
these initial issues but greater
concerns over airdrops being pay2win
persist as a larger conceptual problem
the point is should you be paying money
for that the answer that question is not
so simple it kind of depends on your
expectations in its current state I
would personally say unequivocally no to
paying $19 for h1z1 particularly because
it's supposed to be a free-to-play title
when it's
so why would you do somebody else's job
I mean the publisher is Sony Online
Entertainment you think they don't have
testers on the other hand if you enjoy
the idea of watching a game develop in
front of your eyes and find enough
pleasure in the unfinished experience
and are willing to take the risk that
the end product might not be something
you still enjoy when all the changes are
made then go ahead and drop in Andrew
Jackson honestly dayz still a buggy mess
and that sold over 2 million copies if
that doesn't sound like you wait for
h1z1 to get out of alpha testing which
means it'll be a beta which means it's
actually demo you get the idea
also while the servers are down make
sure to buy a t-shirt in mad oh yeah ok
whoa whoa that zombie was carrying
holiness